oh shit I'm out in the slums again guys
god dammit at least I have my fidget
finger fuck you buzzfeed fuck you I
quit my job at BuzzFeed by the way did
not get fired
I quit me and Dave we're supposed to
quit together but that motherfucker
pussied out on me
god dammit Dave well at least I have my
underwater right
Hello darkeness my old friend
anyway i have to find a new job guys luckily there's a wide
market out there I don't need you buzzfeed
they didn't even use my correct
program pronoun I'm a dragon skater 1969
X X X Y X X X you know what I bet they
fired me because I was white there's one
company I always wanted to work at
Nintendo
let's see what it's like to work at
Nintendo everyone you work hard
I do good job I do nice to your
customers yeah then must you suffer the
headache of returns those fucking
returns I swear to God if dave returns
dr. Mario again I thought it was the
real Super Mario and I got this Tetris
piece of shit game god dammit that
actually happened to me my dad bought me
dr. Mario but I didn't have the heart to
tell him that and he bought the wrong
Super Mario dad I'm sorry but you bought
dr. Mario you didn't buy Super Mario but
in retrospect I actually enjoyed dr.
Mario a lot more even though I in the
beginning I pretended that I liked
playing dr. Mario just because it was
such a nice gift that you gave me even
though probably mom forced you to buy it for me...
Excuse me, I'd like to return this
Nintendo, uh, who do I talk to about that?
Tell you what, you'll need to go
right back here to the electronics area
and they'd be happy to help you. [Uh gosh] to tell you why you
need to return this just go to go to the
guy in the back he'll help you I love
how they make it they openly admit that
they're making it as hard as possible to
return your fucking game mother I'm
going to do for you a customer service
at meal for once you can give this to
you if you take a look at it the fuck
did he do without any Nintendo go
through the apocalypse Jesus Christ
imagine as a matter of that it was
working and now it's not working as so
I'd appreciate if you you know take a
look at it I like to get an exchange for
it if I could I say well do you have
well because I better take a look right
here yeah that's right thank you do you
know what's on here no no I mean the
kids kind of done anything I mean
they're good kids on soap with soft
drink or something all there it puts a
soft drink in there Nintendo you best be
crazy dog no no no it's a soda pop I
don't know it's not soda pop
glad we got that out of the way it's not
soda pop guys it was fine for just I'd
appreciate if I had an exchange on it
That's cum! That's cum
Nintendo what what kind of games did you
play back there are they playing
Custer's revenge the kids Jesus Christ
and how about the customer who tries to
bully you into taking back something you
know isn't broken these guys are a real
problem
you people amaze me you really amaze me
your quality control people they just
have bats in the belfry about this game
boy yep Jay took at home nothing
absolutely nothing no picture I'm pretty
sure it's the EEPROM so if you just want
to take a look at that I fix it myself
but I don't really have the tools so
I'll take my money back I'm sorry you
had a problem caught the music huh here
we go I think this thought is a problem
yeah just needed to turn up the contrast
of it
how's that look oh wow that looks
amazing
whoa he just needed to turn up the
contrast a bit what a fucking moron and
they didn't know the old contrast bit of
course the contrast I think that was
probably my like my kid didn't I'll take
it the controller doesn't work oh I
can't there's a picture but there's no
action possibly I didn't read the
instructions right I take a look here
see how it work
I didn't want to have to bring it in but
I just couldn't get it to work there you
go working up did you try before get it
in you dumb bitch god damn I hate this
guy hate I would hate this job thank you
so much John oh thank you so much I
didn't think about plugging it in thank
you
tell me when you plugged it into you put
it into hey tell you why when you
plugged it in did you plug it up your
ass is that what you did because you're
a fuckin idiot
port number one or port number two I
plated whatever - oh my god
god bless they didn't see anything wrong
with that question his Nintendo so tell
you later where did you which port did
you put it in there was it number one or
number two well plug it into number one
so we could put it as a number two it
won't work you heard it here first folks
Nintendo said it themself if you put it
at number two it won't work god bless
you Nintendo you're a great great
family-friendly company I really
appreciate your family friendliness here
really good that you you know maybe I
can't walk at Nintendo after all they
don't appreciate number two a little
disgusted by this in many cases the
customers simply failed to follow the
simple directions package with their
product most of the times people are
just fucking idiots the training kit is
there to help you when you have or are
given some spare time review it there's
no telling what you might pick up it
will help you during the next occasion
you have to deal with a customer return
a nintendo customer return sounds
ttoo scary for me what other jobs do we
have and now displays with Jake
hi I'm Jay oh god Jake please there you
are sometimes you want to change the
volume on this as well and that we have
to run around to the side here the side
panel will open up if you take the same
key and open the lock on the back of the
display open up that lock open the side
panel if you look right down here you'll
see a little blue block with little
teeny tiny switches on it right above
that is little thing that looks like a
screw head okay take the screwdriver you
got in your kit yep and turn that little
screw head one way or the other to
adjust the volume
that's me one just if I like the volume
up really I how high do you like the
volume say that again please
really I really I okay all right then
good good to know thank you be sure to
put in your screwdriver and you know me
I like it up real loud hi again hi again
take a tube and turn the volume up or
down as you see fit
now you know me I like the volume up
really ah Jesus Christ he scares the
shit out of me I can't imagine working
with him I'll take any other job here we
go I still made water coke see it's up
to you it's up to me cold drink come in
four cups gonna know the size before you
visit biggest small kids meal keep it
straight this is a good deal you do to
fill with ice never use the cart a quiet
life altering story is pathways no
matter the size that's what I say you
know on second thought maybe not maybe
not work at Wendy's man never not God
that was the worst fucking shit I don't
want my customers to have problems
because I didn't do my job right
thank you ma'am have a nice day and come
back Oh John I love to see customers
passes already program robots
don't say the same thing over and over
again like a broken record hi welcome to
Hardee's hi welcome to Hardy hi welcome
to Hardy hi welcome to heart hi welcome
to heart
hi Eddie hi Marty hi welcome to horror
hi hi welcome hi welcome to home parties
hardman damage five-star service hello
and welcome today we'll explore the
meaning of five-star service and how we
can provide it to every guy on care we
make eye contact smile and offer a
simple greeting or a friendly wave Jesus
Christ working service in America must
be a fucking nightmare Jesus Christ how
do you not kill yourself my god oh jesus
lord I must be so soul-crushing to have
that job my god that's why they're
always so fake in America and I'm like
why is everyone so nice to me is it because
I'm Poodewpie ? how that must be it
that's good chicken hey this is the hook
hell yeah that's a nice hook man oh okay
incredible I will work at KFC everybody
'Cause they have the hook!
Guys, I hope you enjoy this video. I'm so excited to be working at KFC
from now on BAM I'm at KFC everyone
frying your chicken wing, boy.  If you ever meet
me there just ask for the hook and
I'll hook you up buddy
but remember you got to smash that like
button for a chance that I can win an
Amazon gift card so please slice that
like one and I'll see you bro in the
next video
frying them chicken wing stay awesome bros
hi welcome to Hardee's
hi welcome to hearty hi welcome to
hearty hi